vous voulez
noblet mauvais
il voulait
quatre années à la céramique
je m'exprime est un peu beaucoup pas
faire beaucoup
je fais passer beaucoup de messages non
nous à ecublens nouvelles formes de
l'ordre haïtienne parce qu'on sait déjà
qu'ils appelaient la tuerie touristique
s'aimer nommé
ces jeunes là sans la fondation se veut
dire trois cadres ne sont pas allés à
l'école
ne pouvant colo colo réunir au bas de la
ville aux mémoires de tous les victimes
du séisme du 12 janvier
c'est un gros arbre plein de branches
avec des feuilles séchées effet est ce
mieux là on l'appellait un bout de vie
c'était pour dit aux haïtiens et à tout
le monde que haïti ne va pas péri après
le séisme nos racines sont très
profondes
olé
c'est nouveau et c'est joli aussi il ya
beaucoup de gens qui nous félicitons
nous avons commencé avec un mur et
légendes et pato de la ville m'ont
demandé de travailler dans le quartier
ou dans leur maison ils nous paient
aussi les revenus de 10 familles
vraiment trop c'est la raison pour
laquelle je vais étudier mon coeur je
vais travailler du tour ou être
accomplie mais réglant j'aimerais
devenir aussi professeur de mosaïca
grands artistes la majorité entre 8
secondes et artistes de demain mais je
lui ai toujours dit que à titre
ok mais avec l'école avec université
vous pouvez quand même devenir n'importe
quoi elle avait un médecin même le
président un avocat maintenant je
commence
pratique et anglais et français j'ai
travaillé dans la mosaïque mais mon
objectif c'est d'être devenir le
photographe et que national j'aimerais
ajouter la diplomatie
au mécano vie